هناك الكثير من النسور هنا ، النسور
الصلعاء هي عبئنا القومي بالنسبة لمعظم
الناس في الولايات المتحدة ، هناك مناظر نادرة ورائعة ،
لكن بالنسبة لنا هذه
مجرد جزء من حياتنا اليومية ، كل شخص
في المدينة لديه نسر سوري
[موسيقى]
أنا كارلين ولوي  ولدت وترعرعت في
ألاسكا وأنا
المدير التنفيذي لمكتب زوار Unalaska على الرغم من أن
جزيرتنا يبلغ طولها 80 ميلًا تقريبًا ، فهناك
ما يقرب من 600 طائر في بضعة أميال مربعة فقط ،
وهو أمر جنوني ، فهناك عدد غير طبيعي
من الطيور هنا لأننا
نساهم في طعامهم  مصدر هذه
النسور الصلعاء مدهش للغاية ونحن نحب
رؤيتهم ولكن عندما يشاركون في
حياتك اليومية يمكنهم القيام
بالمهمات أو عملك صعبًا حقًا ،
فأنت تقرأ شيئًا بسيطًا مثل إرسال
بريد إلكتروني يمكن أن يكون خطيرًا أنا
ضابط مع  قسم
الأمن العام في ألاسكا ، وضع قسمنا
هذه العلامات لتحذير المجتمع
من مخاطر تعشيش
النسور الموجودة بجوار مكتب البريد.
الخاصة للانقضاض ومهاجمة
الأشخاص الذين هم إقليميون للغاية
ويحاولون فقط حماية
أعشاشهم ، عش النسر موجود
هناك مباشرةً وهنا مكتب البريد
أصيب بعض الأشخاص خلال هذه الحوادث
ولكني سمعت أيضًا بعض الأشياء المضحكة  قصص
أنا بام أوز وأركض بينغو هنا في
مركز سينيور كل يوم أحد ، كنت
أحمل هذا الصندوق ، كان يحتوي على شيء مثل
لعبة البنغو ، فجأة
اصطدم جناح برأسي ونزلت المخالب
وأمسك بالصندوق وطارت إلى الأسفل  الشارع
ولم أر صندوق البنغو الخاص بي مرة أخرى ، ولكن إذا كنت
تريد رؤية مجموعة كبيرة من النسور ، فانتقل
إلى مكب النفايات ، أنا ستيف باستوك ، أعمل
في مدينة أونالاسكا ، وهو مكب النفايات
وهو أحد الأماكن المفضلة لدي لأكون أيضًا واحدة
من  أنا
أعلم أن النسور هم زبالون وحيوانات
مفترسة ، لذا فهم يحبون القمامة حتى
يلتقطوا كل ما يعتقدون أنه قد يكون
طعامًا ، اسمي بوب ويلسون ، لقد كنت
أصطاد من بحر بيرنغ وهاربور دوتش
منذ 40  سنوات هاربور الهولندية هي واحدة
من أكبر  موانئ الصيد في
العالم في كل مرة نقوم فيها بالسحب ، نعلم أن
النسور ينتظروننا حتى يتمكنوا من
سرقة أسماكنا أثناء تفريغها ،
أعتقد أنها آفات بالتأكيد ،
لكنها آفات رائعة ، لذلك لا بأس في
أن تصنع  فوضى قاربي الذي هو
نوع من الجزء السيئ لكنه
طائر وطني ونحن نحبهم على أي حال ،
كيف ذلك
[موسيقى]